i'm ticked you're ticked
will arnett was on this show yeah i'm
allowed to have will arnett on if i want
yeah you can but something happened can
i show the clip
i don't i do not remember what you're
talking about okay but i i'm ticked okay
let's show the clip me talking to will
arnett and see what's happening
and i shake a lot of celebrity hands
when they come out here you have a
strong grip thank you and uh yeah who
has the weakest grip
right i mean we want to kind of know
that don't we
i would say
i'm just going to say larry king no and
larry king
i love larry king but when you shake his
hand it's look at this it's like it's
like you're shaking hands with a lab
skeleton it just is
he doesn't work out
it's like someone put a day-old bread in
your hand that's what it feels like
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm sorry larry you were the name that
came to mind stand up oh god
he's gonna hit your boss
get in there
all right all right all right it's a
strong handshake you have a strong
handshake i wouldn't believe that yeah
where did that come from what are you
talking about he asked me but why me
it's not the strongest
that's all but yes i i just came up with
a name i thought you're a good pal you
could take a ribbing actually it was a
compliment in a sense that you could
think of so many people that you've met
and that my name would come to mind
over what it's a great compliment it's a
great compliment yes so you're welcome
now larry we've got other fish to fry so
to speak
i read that you are uh taking hgh human
growth hormone i've been taking it
my wife got a package of it and i
started taking it 18 years ago i take
now i don't get the injections i get the
pills i take two in the morning two at
night human growth hormone that's what
wrestlers and athletes take why are you
taking human growth hormone well for i
don't know why it's banned in baseball
football it's supposed to be just
recover from illness faster that's one
of the things but it's supposed hey it's
a performance enhancing drug well hgh
and you're taking hgh hey do you like
the handshake
anyway it's getting better but i'm just
curious what that's all about that's all
okay i've been taking it and i'm 80
years old
i've gone through heart surgery i have
type 2 diabetes my diabetic doctor says
i'm the best diabetes patient she has
ever seen so we went over the vitamins i
take and the prescriptions i take and
she figures out it has to be hgh have
you grown at all since taking hg no in
fact i lost an inch okay but
i feel i don't get jet lagged when i fly
a lot right i feel terrific right i
don't feel my age you know i'm just i'm
bouncy i'm a little i gotta say you are
very vital you're a great advertisement
for hgh because it seems to be working
for you and it shouldn't be banned i
don't think it shouldn't be banned